record high gas prices are turning into
major speed bumps for americans who plan
to travel this summer this morning the
nation's average price for a gallon of
regular is 4.76
another new record chris van cleave
talked to one driver about the high cost
of going on a trip
pain at the pump is written all over
debbie carl's face looks like you did
almost 100 this time it's awful it's
awful yeah i i'm thinking this is the
second time we fueled up the first time
was 75
so we're gonna spend like
six or eight hundred dollars in gas she
her daughters and grandkids are driving
650 miles each way for a long weekend of
camping are the gas prices ever going to
go down or do you think this is
i hope so but don't expect it to get
better anytime soon says gas buddies
patrick dehaan this may be the low point
for the summer in what could become
certainly a very expensive summer to
fill your tank demand for oil is
outpacing supply
the war in ukraine means millions of
barrels a day of russian oil stay off
the market u.s and opec are increasing
oil production but it's still below
pre-pandemic levels capacity at u.s
refineries that turn crude oil into
gasoline also remains below 2019 output
while demand may peak mid-summer that's
right when hurricane season ramps up
will we see a hurricane disrupt refining
if we do that could prolong how long it
will take to see a reprieve in prices
we're simply biding time until the next
major headline a year ago it would have
cost about 50 bucks to fill up this suv
now
78
that is pain at the pump some relief may
come in the fall but for now prices are
only likely to rise debbie carl says
even if it costs her more to get there
she can't put a price on family time for
cbs mornings chris vancleave daytona
beach florida